a few weeks ago the Australian gamespot
team went off to play evolve we all did
our best at the trapping medic in the
salty and supporting as per our classes
but it all came to naught since the one
of us happened to play a really really
deadly Wraith is how it all went down
ten minds it's terrifying and brutal
Wraith monster took us down in all but
one round so in preparation for evolves
release tomorrow I'm bringing him on to
give you all the tips and tricks as to
how to play the advanced wraith monster
and potentially lose friends in the
process thanks Jess whatever I didn't
play with you in the first place so then
tell me how to play an awesome Rick well
the Wraith has the lowest health and
armor of most monsters so that means you
can't engage in direct combat for as
long as you can with the other ones it's
a quick movement is the key success that
means you should definitely pick the
stamina regeneration part so the Wraith
can teleport a short distance three
times before needing to recharge and
it's this warp ability that lets you get
in and out of combat really fast the
stamina regeneration perk actually makes
these Wolf's recharge faster which
overall let you move around the map with
greater agility so before you start the
match you get to put three points into
any of the Wrights abilities but there's
actually only two that you need to focus
on put one point into abduction this
lets you draw it across the map and grab
an unaware hunter and then pull them
away from their friends
you only need one point in this ability
because it does the job when your stage
one rate perfectly fine put two points
into the supernovae ability this is
crucial and it's something that you need
to activate every single time you went
to combat if your supernova is
recharging you should avoid combat
entirely and teleport away you want to
start the match with two points in
supernova so you can use it quickly to
eat the elite creatures before your
buddies drop into the match and start
hunting you and if your hunters catch up
to you
one full round of whaling on them where
the supernova activated is enough to
incapacitate one of them giving you the
chance to flee as they try and revive
that teammate don't even try to eat your
hunter friends when your only stage one
instead just teleport around the map as
quickly as possible and eat as many
creatures as quickly as possible when
you hit stage to max out supernova so
that you can go toe-to-toe with the
hunters then put your remaining two
points in to decoy
now this spawns a copy of you which
attacks the hunters and does damage
meanwhile turning you invisible and
giving you ample time to slip away
remember to feed a couple of times after
evolving so that you fill your armor
back up but apart from that you're scary
enough even though you haven't hit stage
three all right so now you
to take the hunters now always initiate
combat when they're unaware of you if
they know where you are
teleport away and try and come at them
from different angle because you're so
squishy you need to make every second
count and every second the hunters are
confused is the second that you're not
being shot at your first move should
always be one of two things a stealth
pounce or an abduction if you attack a
hunter while crouched you'll pin them to
the ground and they'll be unable to
recover without the help of teammate
once you do this teleport away
immediately don't sit there and try and
finish off a pinned hunter as the other
hunters come to help line up an
abduction on the one who is going for
the revive if you're successful you'll
have taken two hunters out of action so
as soon as that abduction is over pop
supernova and just wail on them until
that hunter is down do not stop until
they're incapacitated and don't even try
and change targets much of the time
you'll be able to knock them down right
as the supernova is running out activate
decoy and teleport away from the hunters
immediately start lining up your next
attack make sure it's from a different
angle to the first one wait until
supernova has recharged then repeat your
attack pattern from before always focus
on the same hunters you incapacitated
previously if you're knocking down three
times they'll be out of the match until
a dropship arrives repeat this pattern
and your former friends won't even stand
a chance and take it from me they really
weren't I learned that the hard way let
me know if you'll be playing evolve and
if you're more keen to play the hunters
or than one step hopefully these tips
will come in handy when you unlock your
race and I'll catch again next week
if supernovas recharging you should like
avoid combat oh my god don't even try to
hate your hunter from what what don't
even try
oh my god two points into the supernova
bility okay just one up it goes like
this
pop supernova and just wail on him until
that hunter is down